حصل 14 طالبا فلسطينيا هذا العام على منحه
تقدمه مؤسسه امد ايس في العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن لطلاب متميزين تمكنت المؤسسه خلال
العقدين الماضيين من ارسال عشرات الطلاب
الفلسطينيين الى جامعات الامريكيه مهمه
لاتمام رحلتهم العلميه المزيد مع هندراهيم
هذه خطوات صوب النجاح سبقتها رحله بالاف
الكيلومترات قطعتها غاده من غزه الى جامعه
جورج واشنطن في الولايات المتحده حيث توشك
على اتمام دراستها للحصول على الدكتوراه
في المناعه البشريه وتحديدا في فيروس زيك
الخطير بالنسبه الي انه انا صرت عالمه في
الولايات المتحده واني بقدر
اكمل شو شغفي في الحياه وشو انه انا بدي
ادرس هاي امل لكل الطلاب ولكل الناس اللي
في غزه انه ممكن نصلي المستحيل
غاده واحده من قرابه 200 طالب فلسطيني
التحقوا على مدى العشرين عاما الماضيه
باربعين جامعه امريكيه مرموقه بعد حصولهم
على منحه هوب التي تقدمها مؤسسه امد ايست
بهدف تغيير الصور النمطيه عن الشعب
الفلسطيني وتبديلها بصور المواهب والابداع
العلمي والمثابره
ينظر الى الفلسطينيين على انهم ارهابيون
وربما ضحاياه لكننا نرى الان اعدادا
متزايده من اساتذه وطلاب الجامعات بداوا
يدركون ان الفلسطينيين ناجحون ولديهم قدره
تحمل هائله وهم ايضا موهبون
موهوبون بعناد لا ينكسر امام التحديات مثل
هناء ابراهيم ابنه غزه ذات الثانيه
والعشرين من العمر اشعر بالامان هنا لكن
لا تزال كوابيس العيش في منطقه حرب
والصراع تلاحقني وذكريات صور الجنود اصوات
تفجير القنابل وكان هذا احد دوافع لدراسه
علم النفس اردت ان افهم واساعد نفسي وان
اتمكن من مساعده الاخرين ايضا
تنطوي رحله الطالب الفلسطيني للدراسه في
الخارج على صعوبات بالغه بحسب مؤسسه امد
ايست تبدا اولا في اجراءات السفر المعقده
من قبل الاسرائيليين لكن الاشد صعوبه بحسب
هناء وغاده هو الم البعد عن الاهل والاحبه
بس لازم نكابر ونكابر هند ابراهيم العربيه
واشنطن